scusa ma questo estetico ora stamattina
alle 8 clima ma che orario e le 8 del
mattino vi stavo dormendo questa canzone
o è facoltativa solo allora mi è tornato
sentimmo già che ci siamo noi
praticamente sì devo chiedere un favore
ho avuto problemi abbastanza gravi
volevo sapere se mi potevi dagli appunti
di tutte le elezioni
i corsi
non è un problema salve prof solo
un'informazione visto che ho sudato già
tutto mi chiedevo se quelli dispense che
hanno minato a lezione sì lo so che non
sono obbligatorie ecco però mi chiedevo
magari possono essere utili ai fini
dell'esame visto che l'argomento mi è
molto caro e ci tengo davvero tanto a
prendere l'ennesimo 30 e lode
ciao 6 nuova e mi sembrava infatti sa io
conosco tutti può sì sì anch'io sono al
terzo anno fa sì io però sono fuori
corso cioè sono qui da sei realtà è no
no io sono super affezionata a questa
università
la vedi la carta da parati dell'aula me
la sono fatta mettere in camera se mi fa
sentire al sicuro protetta no no no io
non voglio assolutamente laurearmi prima
che prova da in pensione perché si è
capito sono proprio la mia famiglia ci
tengo troppo
il sacco festeggiato il mio compleanno e
segreteria e il cenone di natale immensa
con gli assistenti figaro che sbatte
maglietta o ma la giri to work si va
bene allora dopo cessero contemporaneo
mi voglio sparare birretta da easy ma
tranquilla cazzo ne frega la lezione
tanto c'era tipo in prima fila vedi
quella bionda la sono fatta mica è
passato tutti gli appunti charlize in
franchi va beh guarda che buono quello
che appena entrato erano guardano
guardare adesso che balle pasta
biblioteca non si può neanche parlare
come in corso punto fratello fatti dare
subito il nome anti no aspetta così è
troppo sgamo
guardo tra i seguiti tuo fratello lo
trovo sicuro eccolo è lui una problema
che pacco è fidanzato
cioè lei processo no ma lui no io per
questa sessione sono organizzata
benissimo ed ho subito storia del teatro
e dello spettacolo perché già dato il
parziale è andato benissimo quindi lo
passo sicuro poi passa economia politica
che sto studiando da due mesi e mezzo
quindi mi sono abbastanza preparata al
massimo se mi legano o comunque l'ultimo
appello a disposizione il fluido
estetica perché ho trovato delle
dispense super dettagliate che non ha
nessuno dove c'è proprio tutto il succo
dell'esame così me ne vado in vacanza
tranquilla capito egregio professor
mangiagalli la sua materia mi ha sempre
affascinato al punto che ho capito che
nella vita vorrei proprio come armi di
statistica visto che la stimo molto come
insegnante e come persona soprattutto le
chiederei umilmente un incontro per
illustrare la mia idea di casey
attendo intrepida la sua gentile
risposta
cordialmente mi collo cartelli no ma io
non passerò mai questo esame
cioè è impossibile che lo passi ho
aperto il libro per la prima volta ieri
sera ma te lo giuro tra giuro sulla mia
dignità
ma poi ho scoperto che c'erano tre tutta
l'ultima parte gli ultimi tre capitoli
che io ho capito per una ronda studiare
cioè è la parte più importante quella
tuo dio tocca a me l'attento l'attento
matta perché tanto sono qui ma guardano
tanto so già come va a finire
[Musica]
ho preso 30 no ma ho avuto culo è
cioè al posto simpatica palesemente poi
la prima domanda che mi ha fatto pensare
come ti chiami cioè capito ho avuto
fortuna si no
[Musica]